the only force strong enough to save our
country sometimes politics can seem very
small
why does Al Gore say one thing when the
truth this is one of the first televised
political campaign ads I like Ike it's
so simple it's a catchy song there's an
easy-to-remember rhyme and a man with a
name like Dwight Eisenhower known for
being a military giant it immediately
made personable relatable the I like Ike
ad really was the first campaign
advertisement sent out in a mass media
forum designed to directly sort of
introduce Ike and his supporters to the
broader electorate in 2018 political
campaign ads have become major
productions with complete narrative arcs
like films and can have greater reach
over social media than television
so how did the all-american political
campaign ad come to be and how has it
evolved into a multi-billion dollar
industry that relies on knowing
everything about you well it's a story
about increased access to the everyday
American citizen and it starts with eye
General Dwight the Eisenhower wasn't
really a guy known for his charm he was
a decorated war hero who had brought the
United States to victory during World
War two and when he decided to run for
president in 1952 he wasn't coming with
much or really any experience with
electoral politics so the challenge he
presented to those who were pushing for
an Eisenhower presidency was how do we
take someone so well known and liked who
has no political experience and has
terrible oratory skills and get him
elected enter the television and a big
advertising executive approached
Eisenhower with a plan for a TV ad
campaign called Eisenhower answers
America the campaign was run by a bunch
of Hollywood and advertising bigwigs who
wanted to capitalize on the extreme
growth of television in the United
States during the 1940s and 50s imagine
40 million American households in 1952
had television sets that's 40 million
households that weren't available in
previous election cycles the advertising
campaign was simple several 20 or
30-second spots where Eisenhower was
answering questions about his vision and
while being sold as politically adept
Daniel crease an associate professor at
UNC Chapel Hill says that it was the
Eisenhower TV ad campaign that really
changed in a way where priorities were
for campaigning campaigns start to
contest elections more through air wars
than the ground wars which is to say
that instead of going out knocking on
doors relying on strong political
parties campaigns and candidates
generally make their appeals to the
electorate directly over the airwaves
politics becomes much more about sending
generally undifferentiated messages to a
mass electorate now Eisenhower won the
presidential election in 1952 and the
personable ads had an impact on
converting Democratic voters and non
voters to vote for him the Republican
candidate Eisenhower's political TV ad
campaign success set the tone for how
elections would be fought going forward
and it continues to the election in 1960
with John F Kennedy and Richard Nixon I
want to talk to you for a moment
by that election 90% of American
households had a television set compare
that to just nine percent ten years
earlier and from there the American
political ad just continues to develop
with the infamous Daisy ad in 1964 it
was run by the lyndon b johnson
presidential campaign and attacked the
Republican candidate Barry Goldwater the
Daisy ad was was unique really in that
it was a very direct fear appeal the
Daisy had ushered in sort of a new
generation of much blunter messages
starting in the 80s and 90s overall
spending on election campaigning blew up
with a pretty big focus on TV
advertising more than 300 million
dollars were spent on political
advertising in 1992 for both local and
national elections which totally Dwarfs
a previous record of two hundred and
thirty million dollars just four years
earlier government just isn't working
for the hard-working families of America
now we're focusing a lot on presidential
campaigns and political advertising
because it's those ads that have a
national reach and have impacted the
growth of the political ad in 2000
George Shelby Bush and Al Gore went
head-to-head for the presidency and
probably one of the most consequential
elections in American history the bush
and gore campaign spent a combined 67.1
million dollars in TV ads hitting almost
200,000 spots collectively that year
newspapers say Gore has a problem
telling the truth and that trend of
increasing funding for political
advertising continue to grow as more and
more people especially those who are
younger start to live more and more
online starting in the mid 1990s
campaigns began shifting from running
relatively undifferentiated broadcast
television or cable television ads that
was seen by large swaths of the American
public to increasingly targeted internet
ads that would at first sort of be run
on like newspaper websites or AOL
dial-up internet and
late 90s early 2000s and now to running
ads on platforms like Facebook that
allow campaigns to buy particular
audiences and show content in a hyper
targeted way and it was a candidacy of
Barack Obama that changed everything for
political advertising and not
necessarily for the better while
previous presidential candidates like
Howard Dean in 2004 had used the
internet for campaign fundraising it was
the Obama campaign that used it to
advertise to mobilize voters and to push
back against attacks from opponents at
this defining moment in our history the
question is not are you better off than
you were four years ago
we all know the answer to that the real
question is will our country be better
off four years from now
well then candidate Barack Obama
outspent his opponent John McCain by a
hundred and seventy three million
dollars in 2008 on political advertising
his campaign also relied on YouTube
which was a free space it's hard to
really figure out how much influence the
Obama campaign's focus on internet
campaigning had on young voters but the
2008 election saw the highest number of
young voters come out for Obama than for
any other president since 1972 when exit
polling first started oh and get this
remember this viral YouTube video
[Music]
that ad is the one that's believed to
have put Barack Obama on the map and it
wasn't created for television or by the
Obama campaign but by will.i.am up the
black-eyed peas but it totally became
the Obama campaign's anti-obama
2012 campaign once again changed how the
internet could and would be used for
political advertising anointing that
election the first big data election the
Obama campaign went all-out when it came
to collecting data to better target
voters and Facebook was a huge part of
that push the campaign collected and
studied data on prospective voters to
public information and catered messages
for specific demographic specific areas
and even people that tactic is known as
micro targeting and it was a big and
controversial part of the 2016
presidential election now let's take a
breather for a moment to recap where we
are we've gone from this ad that reached
40 million American households to
political campaign advertising that's
collecting your data and customizing
messaging that targets you wherever you
are
so broadly the implication of that
movement from mass to much more hyper
targeted public's means that campaigns
and other political actors are able to
make increasingly narrow appeals to very
small slices the electorate and even
more importantly those people who are
seeing an ad don't necessarily know that
they're seeing the same ads as other
people they candidate could say one
thing to one group of people and another
thing that to another group of people
depending on what strategically
advantageous and we see what crease is
talking about in the 2016 election
campaigns during that election cycle
then candidate Donald Trump spent a
fraction on political advertising
compared to his opponent Hillary Clinton
who was slated by many to become the
45th president our movie is about
replacing a failed and corrupt political
establishment Trump was amazingly adept
at earning free media coverage by some
academic estimates over two billion
dollars of free media on platforms like
CNN Fox News during the course of the
election the thing that the campaign
then sought to do was to buy advertising
around those themes and target
individuals on platforms especially
Facebook in order to mobilize those
voters further and you can mobilize
voters even more because digital
advertising isn't as passive as TV ad
digital advertising is designed to
mobilize and what I think the Trump
campaign did very effectively was reach
out to people who were Trump supporters
or likely to be sympathizing with them
and then asking them to take action in
some particular way
now while social media and the Internet
overall are powerful tools that can
empower voters
political advertising online is not
regulated meaning there's potential for
anything goes and that anything goes
caused a lot of outrage when it was
revealed in 2017 a uk-based Ambridge
analytic apprise of consulting firm had
gained access to the private information
of almost 90 million Facebook users
through an app that access violated
Facebook's privacy rules and the trust
of millions of users in the platform but
not any federal laws one of the firm's
clients was a Trump campaign it used
data collected on a huge part of the
American electorate to micro-target its
message so again we've gone from I like
Ike to an invasion of privacy just for
political advertising so what's next
where does political campaign
advertising go in a world of big money
and big surveillance
well-nigh only Byrne and Nick Hayes the
people behind Alexander Ocasio Cortez's
viral the courage to change ad think the
future is principled advertising for
principled politicians Bern and Hayes
are the founders of means of production
a socialist production company founded
in the aftermath of a 2016 presidential
election working on ads for a group of
relative newcomer to the mainstream in
the Democratic Socialist of America and
they're not afraid of being very open
about having an agenda we really want to
work with people that are pushing on
politics advancing an agenda
that benefits working-class people we
draw a line that we won't work with
people who take corporate money because
there's no interesting stories to be
told about those people and we also only
work with people who have a socialist
politics because without like an
ideological foundation progressivism is
co-opted and they found success with New
York Democratic congressional nominee
Alexander Ocasio Cortes women like me
aren't supposed to run for office
I wasn't born to a wealthy or powerful
family I reached out to her on Twitter I
explained who we were as means of
production I said we take no corporate
money were socialists and we would
really love to make a campaign video for
you she immediately responded the next
day we got on the phone and a month
later we were in New York I think the
thing that made us want to work with her
which she was unapologetically socialist
and she understood how to articulate
those ideas that met people where they
were at the final results was an ad that
delivered a strong narrative that
intertwined her own life with allies and
experiences of so many of the people who
would be her constituents
it wasn't televised and it went viral
online but after 20 years of the same
representation we have to ask
who has New York than changing for every
day gets harder for working families
like mine to get by the rent gets higher
healthcare covers less and our income
stays the same Ocasio Cortez defeated
her opponent 15-year incumbent candidate
Joseph Crowley in the Democratic primary
she's projected to be the next
representative for New York's 14th
congressional district the viral ad
didn't necessarily introduce her to the
constituents that she had already been
campaigning to for months
but it did introduce her and her
politics to people well outside New
York's 14th district so we've seen
political advertising evolved a lot
since I like Ike first hit the airwaves
in 1952 and that evolution has been tied
to the evolution of how people stay
connected to each other and to the world
around them but how much is political
advertising really worth if surveillance
has become an inseparable part of it hey
guys hope you liked the video let us
know in the comments what some of your
favorite political ads have been and
also let us know has a political ad ever
changed your mind about a candidate
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
and come back next Sunday when we come
at you with another great video